on
six erreurs pour une catastrophe moscow
révèle comment s'est produit l'accident
de tchernobyl c'est une expérience qui a
mal tourné l'attaqué du train postal
version française les gangsters sont
repartis les mains vides mais il ya
trois blessés un homme vit depuis deux
jours avec l'aide d'un coeur mécanique
français il doit lui permettre
d'attendre une greffe
et puis ce jeudi 21 août voici cinq cent
dix sept jours que sont détenus marcel
carton et marcel fontaine 456 jours de
détention pour jean paul kauffmann et
michel seurat 166 jours de détention
pour nos amis d'antenne 2 aurel cornéa
et jean louis normandin et 106 jours
pour camille sontag
il ya toujours sept otages français
détenus au liban
madame monsieur bonsoir quand la nature
se mettent à bafouiller cela nous donne
parfois le résumé grandeur nature de
l'histoire de notre planète
quelques milliers d'années comprimé en
quelques semaines regardez ça se passe
en alaska ou un glacier est en train de
bouleverser la région commentaires
brigitte simonet il s'appelle une barde
il est long de 110 km est haut comme un
immeuble de 30 étages
c'est un des glaciers du sud de l'alaska
après huit siècles de sommeil
l'hiver dernier il s'est brusquement
réveillé en ce moment il se déplace à la
vitesse vertigineuse de 15 mètres par
jour en juin au milieu de craquements
assourdissant il a bloqué un fjord et
fait naître un véritable lac
cette modification du terrain à des
conséquences écologiques catastrophiques
la forêt est en passe d'être englouti
les poissons tels que les saumons et les
arts en fait pour vivre dans l'eau salée
se retrouve dans une eau douce et n'ont
aucune chance de survie même chose pour
les mammifères otaries et phoques qui
n'ont plus rien à manger pour les 450
eskimos qui vivent la lane du glacier
sécurité alors une barde englouti les
tombes de leurs ancêtres menace de
détruire le barrage et l'aérodrome local
seul moyen de communication avec
l'extérieur
les conséquences économiques quant à
elles sont difficiles
ferait sûrement plusieurs millions de
dollars pour l'industrie du bois et pour
la pêche
reste qu'il va falloir s'adapter car les
chais hologue met en garde une barbe
peut continuer à bouger ses eaux peuvent
encore monter
bien sûr ce ne sont que des hypothèses
car l'étude des brusque accélération
enregistrée dans le mouvement des
glaciers ou qu'ils sont capables de vous
pu aller aussi vite qu'ils ont avancé en
fait une barde serait le témoin d'un
changement climatique
depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années on
assiste à une progression des moraines
frontale et un avancement un
engraissement dit on des glaciers qui
récupère des positions qu'ils avaient
abandonnées depuis quelques années de
nombreuses questions restent encore sans
réponse mais une chose est sûre avec ses
glaciers qui se développe
nous sommes en train de vivre un des
plus importants bouleversements
écologiques 10 20e siècle quand les
soviétiques disent tout ou presque sur
l'accident de tchernobyl ça vous donne
froid dans le dos l'histoire est
tragiquement simple l'essentiel de
sécurité avaient été neutralisées pour
mener une expérience c'est fou mais
c'est vrai le scénario avec dominique
tierces et hervé brusini tchernobyl
c'est une centrale comme celle-là 25
avril 14h l'équipe de quart se met au
travail dans la salle de commande
les techniciens doivent procéder à des
essais complexe les tests ont déjà été
retardées
ils veulent en finir c'est la veille du
week end l'ingénieur qui dirige les
essais n'est pas un spécialiste de la
centrale d'ailleurs il connaît mal
fonctionnement du réacteur
de fait dès le départ les techniciens
ont des problèmes pour doser la
puissance du réacteur et pendant neuf
heures ils fonctionnent de manière
anormale 23 heures l'équipe passe dans
la phase active du test ce qu'on leur
demande c'est de se mettre dans la
position d'un automobiliste qui
prendrait les risques maximum rouler
dans une voiture dont la direction est
bloquée sans frein sans accélérateur 100
circuits de refroidissement voilà
comment schématiquement cela s'est
traduit à tchernobyl à une heure du
matin dans les conditions fixées pour le
test
les techniciens sont débordés et
pourtant qu il poursuivre l'expérience
comme dans cette simulation les circuits
de refroidissement ont été coupés ce qui
occasionne un regain de la puissance du
réacteur
c'est une caractéristique du procédé
utilisé par les soviétiques en france la
même manoeuvre provoquerait
l'étouffement de la réaction autre
handicap
le deuxième dispositif de sécurité a lui
aussi était neutralisée l'activité du
réacteur est normalement régulé par des
barres dit de commandes une rame 3
devant l'imminence de l'accident le
dispositif qui actionne ses bars est
enfin déclencher en les faisant
descendre au coeur du réacteur les
techniciens espèrent freiner la réaction
en cours
trop tard 1h24 c'est l'explosion pour
les spécialistes français toute cette
accumulation d'erreurs rendez la
catastrophe parfaitement inévitable un
excès de confiance des gens et une
insuffisance de préparation aux
accidents car c'est fondamental il faut
que les opérateurs d'une centrale
nucléaire
sache non seulement faire fonctionner
bien leur installation
mais est une claire conscience des
risques et de la manière dont on peut
faire face à ces risques
les sas ce deuxième terme n'était de
toute évidence mal connue pour eux et
tout particulièrement les risques de
laisser lui-même qu'ils ont fait un
coeur mécanique pour aider rennes-om à
vivre le temps de recevoir une véritable
greffe ce n'est pas tout à fait nouveau
sinon que ce que ray français et que
c'est la première fois qu'il est utilisé
de la sorte le patient un homme de 44
ans était sur le point de mourir
il va bien ce soir il est même sorti de
son lit et récupère peu à peu en
attendant une nouvelle opération mais
définitive cette fois voici les
précisions de l'uci soboul le coeur de
ce patient victime d'une maladie
coronarienne était dimanche dernier en
bout de course
l'équipe médicale n'avait pas trouvé de
coeur humain qui puisse lui être greffés
elle a alors tenté la seule intervention
possible poser une assistance cardiaque
externe tout en laissant en place le
coeur malade
cette pompe rotative est en somme un
choeur externe posés en parallèle elle
est sur un débit cardiaque mais ne
dépend pas de la fréquence cardiaque du
malade mise au point il y a dix ans elle
a depuis été largement utilisés
dans les cas par exemple de détresse
respiratoire donné par 7 pompes est
essentiellement destinée à fournir une
circulation dans un oxygénateurs mise au
point par la société rhône poulenc
utilisés dans des cas de détresse
respiratoire aiguë nous avons considéré
que cette pompe d'assistance
d'assistance avait des caractéristiques
satisfaisante pour permettre une
assistance temporaire en cas de détresse
ventriculaire en attente de
transplantation ou pour passer un cap
dramatique lorsque les patients peuvent
avoir des apparts us aiguë pouvant
conduire au décès si le coeur n'a pas le
temps de récupérer ce type
d'intervention a déjà été tentée avec
succès par le professeur carpentier en
février dernier l'appareil était alors
plus sophistiqué que celui ci mais il
s'agissait aussi de soutenir
provisoirement le coeur défaillant
rien à voir donc avec ces coeurs
artificiels américain de véritables
prothèse chargé de remplacer
définitivement le coeur malade
cette assistance cardiaque a permis au
patient de survivre il faut maintenant
lui trouver un donneur compatible pour
qu'une grèce soit réalisé la redevance
télévision en france a baissé de 6 et
demi pour cent ce n'est pas encore
officiel mais c'est une quasi-certitude
506 fonds lieu de 5 141 francs pour la
couleur et 333 francs au lieu de 356
fente pour le noir et blanc de toute
façon suppression de la redevance sur
les magnétoscopes mais ça c'était prévu
reste maintenant à savoir si le service
public disposera dorénavant des fonds
nécessaires puisque la publicité devrait
augmenter très faiblement l'année
prochaine et l'année suivante seule
indication on nous promet on nous promet
que les budgets des chaînes publiques
resteront à peu près stable
l'explication alain valentini pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la télé
la redevance sera abaissée l'an prochain
d'environ 6,5 pour cent à la suite de la
privatisation de tf1
elle devrait s'élever à 500 6 francs au
lieu de 541 pour la couleur et 333
francs au lieu de trois cent cinquante
six pour le noir et blanc
la taxe sur les magnétoscopes et en
supprimer la redevance rapportera ainsi
6,2 milliards de francs c'est moins
qu'en 1986 par ailleurs les ressources
publicitaires des chaînes
augmenteront très faiblement pour rester
globalement inférieure à 25% des
ressources globales
dans ces conditions les budgets pourront
ils être stable équilibré
plusieurs mesures en tout cas sont
prévues par exemple les 300 millions d'
aide à la création accordée à la 7
seront reconduits l'an prochain de même
fr3 recevra 30 millions de francs en
particulier pour la reconstitution de
son stock de films
enfin autre source d'économies les
compressions d'effectifs essentiellement
le non remplacement des départs à la
retraite selon un rapport de
l'inspection des finances
les sureffectifs aurait été évalué à 800
personnes sur un total dans
l'audiovisuel public de plus de 18 mille
salariés de nouveaux signes de faiblesse
pour le franc aujourd'hui notamment par
rapport au deutschemark appréciation des
financiers la banque de france n'a pas
souhaité le france ces dernières heures
le dollar de son côté enregistre un
léger mieux les retraites mensualisés en
totalité dès la fin de cette année c'est
la généralisation du système déjà
largement répandue et qui devient donc
la règle en décembre prochain
philippe séguin qui souffle le froid le
médiateur social estime que le chiffre
record du chômage de juillet sera
probablement battu au mois d'août
il faut attendre dit-il l'automne pour
connaître les premiers effets des
mesures décidées cet été en attendant
monsieur séguin prépare un nouvel
arsenal qui veut favoriser de nouvelles
formes d'emploi sur ce point ils se
retrouvent d'ailleurs avec edmond maire
il s'agit essentiellement d'officialiser
les petits travaux et d'encourager les
activités de type social reste matin
trouver un cadre à tout cela
ce pourrait être les associations c'est
une enquête de geneviève moll
profession aide ménagère faire le ménage
repassez laver faire les courses
s'occuper des personnes âgées et surtout
les écouter les écouter revivre leurs
souvenirs honneur avait allié avec des
touches je fis chef et prévient qu'un du
filet et ça fait longtemps que vous êtes
parti obuts ne change
ce n'est ni avec neuf ni un métier
facile ni bien rémunérés mais lorsqu'on
n'a pas autre chose
auparavant je travaillais dans une
société de composants électroniques
et puis je faisais la main tension et
quelquefois d'activer facturière méprise
ferme intention
oui et puisque j'ai été licenciée pour
raison économique
je suis resté deux ans chômage et puis
j'ai trouvé ça je les prie vous êtes
payé combien un seul gros problème
justement savez des fois moins le smic
ou des fois plus ça dépend vous
travaillez robidas par jour la période
d'été les sucs sommes des gens sont
partis disons six à sept heures ça
dépend des autres m'en bats les huit
heures et 19 heures de travail à
quelques rues de là à 28 66 centièmes
qu'est ce qui les motive pourquoi ne
sont elles pas femme de ménage puisque
c'est un métier difficile d'être aide
ménagère je pense qu'une femme de ménage
à s'occupe d'abord d'une maison qui est
vraiment manier une balle l est et le
chiffon tandis qu'elle ménagères c'est
s'occuper d'une personne non c'est pas
un homme différent je crois est tout un
côté
affective quand même elle apporte une
présence auprès des personnes âgées
on a beaucoup de peine de retraités qui
n'ont pas de famille proche
les personnes âgées comme celle ci il y
en attisant mille en france aujourd'hui
il y en aura un million deux cent mille
en l'an 2000 il faudra pour s'occuper
d'elle de plus en plus d'être ménagères
voilà donc un gisement potentiel
d'emploi du temps partiel certes
débutant de travail
si demain on a de l'argent de quelque
chose que ce soit par lequel en retraite
ou par un autre mode de financement
on embauche immédiatement on créer des
centaines d'emplois et en plus on fait
rimer ya aussi des économies à la
sécurité sociale
il faut maintenant trouver de nouveaux
moyens de financement pour créer des
emplois à la table on pense déjà une
possible exonération des charges
sociales pour les associations toutefois
les personnes âgées la cgt bien décidés
à occuper le terrain la rentrée déjà une
indication le traditionnel meeting du
retour de vacances sera cette année
remplacée par une manifestation
interprofessionnelle dans les rues de
paris
ce sera le 9 septembre renault quittent
le mexique la régie ferme son usine dans
ce pays où les ventes sont insuffisantes
et puis le budget de la nouvelle
calédonie adopté par le congrès du
territoire au terme de débats très vifs
entre majorité et opposition c'est à
dire anti indépendantistes et
indépendantistes l'illustration en tout
cas de l' escalade verbale apparues ces
derniers jours à la veille du voyage de
jacques chirac sur les positions et les
déclarations respectives
voici le commentaire de pierre à leur
premier durcissement le week-end dernier
dans l'île de lifou avec le congrès du
fln 15
si les indépendantistes décide de rester
au sein des institutions régionales
il critique vivement le gouvernement qui
selon eux remettent en cause les acquis
du plan pisani il affirme aussi que
seule la population kanak doit peser
lors du référendum prévu l'an proches
jean-marie tjibaou fait même une
concession aux plus extrémistes
en réintégrant au sein du gouvernement
provisoire
or de kanaky ianu reggae flindé bur que
l'on dise où l'affluence bible réaction
des anti-indépendantistes par la voix du
député rpcr jacques lafleur
ils demandent la dissolution de ce
gouvernement kanaky bernard pons
emboîtent le pas nous sommes en
république et dans une république dans
une démocratie comme la nôtre il ne peut
y avoir qu'un seul gouvernement qui le
gouvernement légal
c'est le gouvernement de la france toute
autre organisation groupement qui se
déclarent gouvernement provisoire se
situe comme un groupement de fait qui
peut avoir pour but de porter atteinte à
l'intégrité du territoire national et
qui tombent sous le coup de la loi et
vous ne craignez pas qu une semaine de
l'arrivée de jacques chirac d'une telle
décision provoque un regain de tension
sur place moi je ne crois jamais que le
respect de la loi provoque ici ou là un
regain de tension ce qui provoque des
tensions c'est le non respect de la loi
réponse de jean marie tjibaou on ne
dissout pas la volonté indépendante hic
le problème de l'éducation et tant que
ce problème n'est pas résolu
il n'y a pas d'exemple
problème demeurera comme une pomme de
discorde sur la prospection de l'avenir
si la situation reste calme en nouvelle
calédonie le nouveau commissaire jean
montpezat arrivés la semaine dernière à
nouméa à d'emblée prévenu
la france ne laissera pas se recréer le
désordre nul doute surtout à quelques
jours de la visite du premier ministre
que les consignes seront scrupuleusement
appliqué les visites de l'été de
françois mitterrand après les équipages
de canadair après les sinistrés de la
charité sur loire le chef de l'état a
rendu une courte visite surprise en
bretagne où marin bénévoles chargés du
secours en mer c'est une visite qui
intervient précisément deux semaines
après le naufrage d'un canot parti
porter secours à des plaisanciers
il y avait eu cinq morts les cinq marins
du bord commentaires gilles boulet ne
vend les pavés ventre et du canot de
sauvetage de l'aber wrac'h l'hommage de
françois mitterrand aux sauveteurs
bénévoles
il y a deux semaines sur ce cas nos cinq
hommes sont partis une mission dont ils
ne sont jamais revenus quelques minutes
de sorties en mer pour le président sur
une embarcation vécu la base de
sauvetage ne peux plus remplir sa
mission
alors ici on attendait un geste de
françois mitterrand il a promis 3
millions de francs de quoi jeter un
navire robuste deux heures seulement
passer en terre bretonne quelques mots
de réconfort pour la veuve d'un des
disparus
un peu d'espoir pour la baraque arles
sur far west avec un western à la sauce
française dans les bouches du rhône
entre arles justement et saint martin de
crau intra costa l'attaqué par un
commando de malfaiteurs la cavalerie est
arrivé juste à temps
les gangsters ont dû abandonner leur
butin il ya quand même trois blessés
dont un grièvement atteinte au visage
reportage sur place nicolas jacobs et
robert rosier une route un pont de
chemin de fer il ne manquait que le
train glasgow londres pour refaire un
coup devenu historique
mais aujourd'hui c'était le marseille
lyon qui était visé et l'histoire ne
s'est pas répétée un scénario pourtant
solide quoique classique un signal
saboter le train s'arrête une douzaine
de malfrats encagoulés et puissamment
armés surgissent des coups de feu des
vitres brisées des coups de crosse et
les 40 postis répartis en huit voitures
réduit à l'impuissance
avec un goût fait braquer vous me tape
la bande du loyer
commence alors une fouille en règle les
voleurs sont connaisseurs seuls les
intéressent les sacs reconnaissables à
leur couleur contenant des valeurs 24
ans tous mais c'est là que l'histoire
bascule
la route est toute proche un
automobiliste intrigue et a prévenu les
gendarmes
au moment où les malfrats saute dans
leur voiture ils tombent nez à nez avec
une camionnette de gendarmerie et en tir
à bout portant dans le trafic et ils ont
dû partir vers la voie rapide pour
récupérer d'autres véhicules pour
s'enfuir mais entre les gendarmes et la
voie rapide il y à un marécage résultats
abandonnant alors le butin dans leur
véhicule les malfrats rete 4 voitures
circulant sur la route les conducteurs
sont priés de descendre l'un d'eux trop
lent reçoit une balle dans la mâchoire
les braqueurs quant à eux s'évanouissent
dans la nature mais sans argent à
saint-martin-de-crau il y avait bien une
route un pont un train postal mais il y
avait aussi des gendarmes
à quelques jours de l'anniversaire de
l'attentât du petit-clamart contre le
général de gaulle à des principaux
activistes de l'oas qui faisait partie
du complot vient de tomber pour
escroquer au paraguay jorge battle à 63
ans surnommée la boiteuse souvenez vous
en et qui avait bénéficié de la loi
d'amnistié en 1968 vient d'être arrêté
donc dans la capitale paraguayenne un
journaliste chilien exilé en france
après huit ans de prison dans son pays
il était accusé de publier une revue
clandestine il vient donc d'arriver à
paris
michel mompontet vient de le rencontrer
il témoigne des conditions de sa
libération et de ces années ces huit
années de détention et fois ya là car ce
n'est pas le cas on acceptait la prison
de talent car une représentante du
conseil mondial des églises
organisations humanitaires qui s'occupe
des négociations entre le gouvernement
pour les prisonniers politiques
il m'a appris que sous cette pression le
dictateur avait finalement signé mon
ordre de mise en liberté
comment se sont passés vos sept années
de prison les na'vi la vie politique
chilienne est fluctuante
un peu comme une spirale il y a des
moments de lutte intense auxquelles
correspondent des répression très dure
bien évidemment quand la répression est
très actif dans le pays
elle se répercutant les prisons dans ces
moments là mes camarades et moi avons
été sauvagement torturé d'autant plus
que la dictature me considérer comme un
personnage dangereux
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela qu'ils m'ont
transféré successivement dont plus de 10
prison moi je suis de santiago et pour
m'éloigner de ma famille on m'a déplacer
fréquemment à lire car c'est la victime
taipei 20 et les droits de l'homme au
chili et à mal ça va très mal
voilà cela ne fait même ton pire est le
parrain des parrains de la mafia
américaine devant ses juges aux états
unis john gotti est l'un des principaux
responsables du syndicat du crime
américain son procès vient de commencer
il témoigne en tout cas de la
détermination de la justice américaine
dans sa lutte entamée contre la cosa
nostra
hervé brusini voiture blindée emmené en
armes
l'escort de john gotti pour son arrivée
au palais de justice
john gotti le voici filmé au temps de sa
splendeur 45 en tenue impeccable
souriant en fait l'un des hommes les
plus redoutés des états unis il dirige
la mafia new yorkaise spécialiste de la
contrebande des paris illégaux du racket
et selon la police américaine
expert dans l'élimination de tous ses
concurrents des 185 paul castellano dit
gros paul le boss de la cosa nostra et
son homme de confiance
thomas bilotte tous les deux a battu
pour les enquêteurs ces deux meurtres
sont signées john gotti petit prend
ainsi la tête du clan gambino celui qui
il n'ya pas si longtemps encore
contrôler l'aéroport john fitzgerald
kennedy à new york
de quoi assurer à la famille le transit
de la drogue par tonne paraît-il mais
gotti n'en restera pas là
son propre lieu temps devenait trop
ambitieux un engin explosif dissimulé
sous sa voiture et franck b chicos envol
pour le paradis de la pègre aujourd'hui
géant gauthier dans le box des accusés
parce qu'ils étaient trop bavard son
club de chasse était placé sur écoutes
téléphoniques principaux thèmes de
conversations meurtre et chantages peine
encourue 40 ans de réclusion depuis deux
ans la justice américaine est ainsi
parvenu à mettre sous les verrous
la quasi-totalité des parrains de la
mafia new yorkaise après englouti porte
toujours les costumes mais il ne sourit
plus
les piscines espagnols semblent
décidément convenir aux nageurs français
après l'argent de stéphane caron trois
nageurs a été qualifié aujourd'hui en
finale à tout comme d'ailleurs les types
du 4 x 100 m libre messieurs
et puis ces dernières heures ont vu
tomber quatre records de france
déception en revanche pour la natation
synchronisée
il manquait une marche au podium pour
que les françaises ils trouvent leur
place
marc maisonneuve la france termine à la
4e place du championnat du monde par
équipes de natation synchronisée
l'équipe de france championne d'europe
l'an passé à sofia confirme elle est
dans le sillage des trois meilleurs
mondiaux tant en individuel que par
équipes comme le confirme d'ailleurs son
leader muriel hermine
l'europe a mis un pied dans la porte des
podiums mondiaux
je crois que maintenant à tous les pays
de pousser derrière cette troisième
place en solo et je crois que maintenant
tout est permis à strasbourg sur la plus
haute marche
strasbourg je ne sais pas parce que mon
cerveau cette médaille toutefois je sais
pas encore si je vais continuer à nager
je crois que j'ai besoin de me reposer
de vacances et puis on verra après la
france devance donc l'union soviétique
une place à préserver
en attendant une montée en puissance
possible à strasbourg
la prochaine échéance française
oui puis l'ont de résultats que l'on
m'apporte donc sur ces championnats du
monde de natation de madriers d'abord
dans le 100 m brasse dames et bien la
finale était remportée par l'allemande
de l'est sylvia à guérard et qui empoche
du même coup le record du monde en une
minute 8 secondes 11 centièmes et puis
pour le 4 x 100 m libre messieurs dans
lesquels les français étaient engagés eh
bien ce sont les américains qui ont
qu'ils ont remportée devant les
soviétiques et les allemands de l'est
n'est pas en revanche l'idée de ce
qu'ont fait les français car le dff ne
le dit pas quand les jeunes français ont
des ailes ils font le tour de france
aérien vous pouvez l'imaginer ils
étaient 60 au départ qui avait décidé de
se partager le ciel entre brest et paris
l'arrivée est prévue ce samedi à paris
et vous allez le voir pas besoin d'être
fortuné pour être passionné tout autant
que champion reportage thierry blancot
et jean-françois chevet une escadrille
de vieux coucous symbole de l'époque
héroïque
insolite la carte de visite du tour de
france aérien des jeunes pilotes
un peloton de 60 appareils aux commandes
de jeunes garçons et filles âgés de 17 à
21 ans présenté par leur aéro clubs
sélectionnés après les épreuves
régionales
ils n'ont vu débourser que 400 francs
pour s'engager
mais au delà de l'épreuve elle-même
comment font-ils pour voler toute
l'année l'inter donc je suis dans une
ambiance de pilotes et les voyages en
poste c'est ça ça stimule et ça donne
envie de piloter le méchant mais ne
beaucoup et je fais dans mon art au club
mais je pilote
voici son tour grâce à mes parents je me
prive de tout pour ça je ne vais pas en
moi je n'ai pas de moutons je n'ai rien
du tout je vis pour l'aviation
uniquement pour ça le tour de france
aérien permette à ses participants
d'effectuer 25 heures de vol
complètement prise en charge par la
fédération nationale aéronautique et
quelques sponsors
une aubaine mais pour pratiquer en cours
d'année ces jeunes pilotes doivent
débourser en moyenne 300 francs par
heure de vol de véritables sacrifices
pour des tarifs encore trop élevé dont
la baisse passe par des efforts en
matière de technologie il faut
construire plus léger et plus économique
autre souhait de la fédération nationale
aéronautique la détaxe des carburants
les quarante deux mille adhérents des
550 aéro club de france attendent
l'application de ces mesures
il y aura beaucoup plus de l'imagination
qu'on pourra avoir au niveau en
particulier des matériels
c'est à dire que on peut très bien
aujourd'hui on a les moyens
technologiques experts à concevoir que
cet avion puisse coûter moitié moins
cher que coûte les avions que l'on
connaît actuellement et qui gère en
particulier sont tous d'origine
américaine
le tour de france aérien formule de
promotion de l'aviation civile sans
doute cette a eu pour cent d'entre eux
deviennent de véritables professionnels
de l'aéronautique pour les autres le
plaisir à ce retard est il un tacle
alors pourquoi ne pas essayer arrivée et
résultats du quarter aujourd'hui 15 5 13
et 11 rapports dans l'ordre pour 507 16
1000e 32 francs et un rapport pour 5
fort mais dans un ordre différent 1336
feront mieux maintenant que les machines
à chewing gum aux boissons gazeuses
voici un appareil qui va vous changer la
vie à n'en pas douter c'est le
distributeur automatique de chemises
regarder cinq modèles 4 tailles et un
seul prix 290 francs clientèle visée les
grands hôtels les aéroports et les gares
tout le monde sait qu'on manque de
schmidt paiement par carte de crédit
comme pour les sens mais là pas question
de faire le plein imaginez que les
manches soit trop peu et puis la météo
maintenant en compagnie et bien c'est
logique nous avons à faire en ce moment
1 et est bicéphale une tête au soleil et
une tête dans les nuages et demain c'est
la dépression qui l'emportera regardez
la photo satellite
cette dépression est situé au large de
l'atlantique à ce centre est sont
associés des perturbations qui son rôle
dans le sens inverse des aiguilles d'une
montre
une première perturbation effleuré notre
pays sur la moitié nord une seconde
descendre à demain mais elle sera plus
large plus active elle se manifestera
c'est ce que nous allons voir sur la
carte
elle se manifestera par un ciel couvert
du cotentin au nord au bassin parisien
jusqu'aux vosges et les nuages de vent
de la pluie elle donnera aussi des
nuages très nombreux accompagner
toutefois de quelques éclaircies de la
bretagne jusqu'à la france comptait
centre massif central et aquitaine enfin
sur le quart sud est et sur la corse
la journée sera ensoleillée mais en fin
de soirée on pourra craindre quelques
orages et signaler toutefois que le
mistral est tombé mais qui pourrait très
bien renaître dimanche prochain côté
températures elles sont en baisse c'est
très net
nous sommes maintenant en dessous des
normales saisonnières de 16 à 25 degrés
sur la moitié nord de 23 à 30 degrés sur
la moitié sud
et puisque je vous parlais du mistral je
voudrais vous dire que au niveau des
incendies on arrive à un bilan c'est
catastrophique puisque on sait qu'on
aura probablement à la fin de la saison
à peu près 40 mille hectares de forêt
brûlés demain demain ce sera le vendredi
22 août trois minutes
soleil en moins il se livre à 6h54 se
couchera 20h50 2 et les fabris seront à
l'honneur la dernière journée à l'état
aux environs de 23 heures 10 avec
patrick richard mollet il y aura un
débat qui promet d'être intéressante
puisque patricia recevra rené de
laportalière directeur général de
l'express et jean daniel directeur du
nouvel observateur thème de la joute la
politisation de la presse hebdomadaire
demain à 6h45 votre premier rendez vous
c'est télématin bonsoir admirateurs